le poste frontalier de palanca se trouve
à une cinquantaine de kilomètres
seulement de dessin c'est par la petite
moldavie que des centaines de milliers
d'ukrainiens ont déjà pu fuir le conflit
il fallait faire quelque chose pour
aider ces gens qui fut une crise à côté
de notre pays dit christina qui comme de
nombreux moldaves participent à des
activités de bénévolat mais en moldavie
on ne voit pas que des gestes de
solidarité à l'endroit des réfugiés
depuis le début de la guerre les
ukrainiens font l'objet d'une campagne
de désinformation sur les réseaux
sociaux
dans cette vidéo publiée sur tictoc sept
internautes parlent de pillage et de
réfugiés qui attaquent des camionneurs
et volent leurs véhicules ici cet homme
reproche au gouvernement d'accueillir
des ukrainiens qui roulent en voitures
luxueuses alors que la moldavie est l'un
des pays les plus pauvres d'europe un
discours truffé d'exagération selon la
journaliste maria wassyla che tiemann
montrer patte crimson ghost rider pour
lui si elle reconnaît que le poids
économique est important pour le
gouvernement elle explique qu'une
immense majorité des réfugiés qui reste
en moldavie sont hébergée par de la
famille ou des amis depuis le début de
la guerre cette vérificatrice de faits
constatent une augmentation dans la
publication de fausses nouvelles dans
cette ancienne république soviétique où
se trouve toujours un territoire
auto-proclamé appuyée par la russie la
désinformation est un problème loin
d'être inédit pendant le 30 ans de
l'existence de ce pays on a été toujours
confrontés à des fausses informations
comme ça à la propre compte et j'ose
dire qu'il ya qu elle venue surtout de
l'est surtout de la fédération russe la
moldavie à l'état moldave n'ai jamais
été prêt préoccupait vraiment par la
sécurisation de l'espace informationnel
cette fois ci les autorités ont décidé
d'agir à la recommandation du conseil de
l'audiovisuel les distributeurs moldaves
ont suspendu temporairement la
retransmission des missions
d'information venant de russie d chaîne
très influente dans ce pays où plus de
10 % de la population est russophone
mais si la société très partagés en fait
très partagés et les gens il ya beaucoup
de gens qui croient à ces informations
la guerre en ukraine avec ses
conséquences politiques et économiques
risquent de fragiliser davantage la
moldavie le pays qui fait déjà face à
d'énormes défis
mais pour christine à la crise aura au
moins prouvé que malgré la pauvreté de
leur pays la générosité est une
ressource dans dispose abondamment les
citoyens de la moldavie ici la fin de
bouvy auclair radio canada n'est pas le
cas